[Music]
all right cool anybody else want to
share
pete go ahead my brother
hey everybody uh so um myself
and a guy called roy he's on the academy
bought a house this week congrats
brilliant
yeah legislation mcp right funny
that it sounds normal in
this environment in this community
to say oh we bought a house this week
it's like okay cool
like that's no doubt happen i got a new
phone
i went out i i got a nice i ordered a
nice takeaway this week
oh and i bought a house this week it's
like okay you bought a house
and it just feels normal weird
environment which is incredible so all
right go on
tell us about it yeah so it's a brr deal
infinity return again uh 58 grand in
doncaster
uh reval's 100 and then
everything out at the end and i've seen
some of pete's deals
pete i've seen i've been around i've
been i went around one of his houses a
couple of weeks ago
what an honor that was what's that oh
thank you what an honor that was funny
around
well it was an honour for me as well you
know because it it's just great to be
able to go in people's deals
and and see what you know see what other
people are doing and the deal was
fabulous that
i know deals are good when i go in them
and i almost feel a little bit jealous
if i go into a deal and i'm like oh man
i kind of want i i like this
house because normally when i go in
people's houses
investors houses estate agents take i'm
like
it's all right but i wouldn't buy this
you know this
this might look nice but the figures are
terrible
whereas people's houses who are educated
who are
sophisticated investors and i'm like man
i like this house i wish i could have
bought this house
that's what i know that's that's when i
know that i'm in the right place so
where where is this deal then pete it's
in donnie
doncaster
it's a bit of a dump at the moment but
it's one of them old kind of victorian
terrace types with the the triangular
dormer on the top so
we're going to get it out with laminate
floors make it look real
lovely on all floors and then white
paint it and bring out the features
so uh yeah it's a really big place the
rooms are like
15 foot square massive
and the two things you can't change size
and location
yeah exactly there's a dump
but it's a good size and it's in the
right location
boom shaka just in the wrong
part of town or it's too small
even if it's in great condition you
can't add any value to it
so that's great stuff pete who did you
say you bought that with
roy from the academy so talk to me about
how that was structured that deal
so um yeah so i
me and my current jv partners and
address
so address josh and lauren uh all came
up on saturday
to look around a few houses and get a
feel about what we're looking for on vrr
and just get a bit of heads up on what
we're after because we're gonna deal
source together all of us
and then i took him round that one i'd
arranged it we saw
sixty thousand uh william h brown was
the estate agent
then we got there a bit earlier we had a
walk around the neighborhood
uh made sure there were parks up was a
new estate just around the corner
it's going to lift the area a bit and
then
did all the figures got the spreadsheet
together because we were like looking at
selling it as a
partnership first and then when i did
the figures it was like 58 grand
in and a grand hundred grand rebound and
30 grand 35 grand profit it's just
ridiculous not to do it
so just yeah so then i went on to the
forum
and posted up i wanted a jv and
roy wrong me in two minutes after that
we've done a deal by
10 minutes later because roy's got some
cash that he wants to
invest and he wants the experience so i
said look
you know do these all the time so why
don't you partner
i'll show you all the way through it
we'll do it all together
we'll get all the builders together and
we'll do some work there as well
you'll get the experience and the jv and
then you'll get 10 grand
we'll split the profit 10 grand each and
er
and walk away that's awesome how much
how much money are you putting in with
your own money
50 grand worth of pension nice
on the side i love what pete's doing
pete is absolutely dominating at the
moment so let's give peter a hand
could you just share could you just
share a couple of top tips about
finding deals because you're clearly
very good at it
yeah the the key thing it what i do when
i'm hunting and i show
all of my partners this is i'm going
zupla put a 40-mile search from my house
and then pick off the cheapest 20
and then look at all of them and make
sure and then
out of that 20 i'll probably be able to
shortlist ten of them
and go around all of these state all of
those houses
and then pick off the two or three i
want a deal source and
buy out of those so basically it's a
little bit of a numbers game
it's a little bit of a knowing what
you're looking for game
a negotiation game and also educating
estate agents right telling them what
you want
yeah and the other thing is and the
my partners mentioned this was when we
were seeing the estate agent at the time
i was more friendly than before i was
going to be
that's the key is it's all about people
buy off people
people sell to people yeah it's all
about being that person who's going to
be the one that sticks in your mind
if you're the state agent oh he was a
nice guy the guy came around last
saturday he didn't get that house but
this one
and he's got 50 grand so i'll give him a
ring and that's how you get the estate
agents on board
that is so true as someone that used to
be an estate agent i used to be an agent
i used to if i liked somebody an
investor
oh then yeah i don't owe them anything
but just because they've been nice to me
and they seem like a nice woman or a
nice man
you kind of when you get a potential
deal you think i'll find them first
yeah first because you actually want to
help them out you want to see them do
well so
that's a great tip um